JACKIE: TWO PEOPLE SHOT
OUTSIDE -- SEAN: TWO PEOPLE SHOT
OUTSIDE LEE ZELDIN'S HOME IN
SHIRLEY, NEW YORK.
HIS 16-YEAR-OLD DAUGHTERS WERE
HOME DOING HOMEWORK AND
CONGRESSMAN ZELDIN RELEASING A
STATEMENT READING AFTER MY
DAUGHTERS HEARD THE GUNSHOTS AND
SCREAMING, THEY RAN UPSTAIRS AND
LOCKED THEMSELVES IN THE
BATHROOM AND IMMEDIATELY CALLED
911.
MY DAUGHTERS ARE SHAKEN BY OKAY.
LIKE SO MANY NEW YORKERS, CRIME
HAS LITERALLY MADE ITS WAY TO
OUR FRONT DOOR.
LISTEN, GIANNO, YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED THIS CRIME FIRSTHAND
AND WHAT POLITICAL IMPACT IS
CRIME GOING TO HAVE ON THE NEXT
ELECTION?
GIANNO: I THINK A HUGE IMPACT
LOOKING AT HISPANIC VOTE FOR
EXAMPLE.
THIS IS A NUMBER TWO ISSUE.
JUST LOOK AT AMERICANS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, 77% OF AMERICANS
VIEW THIS AS A MAJOR ISSUE.
GOING BACK TO MY HOMETOWN OF
CHICAGO, ON JANUARY 1, THEY'RE
GOING TO ENACT A SAFETY ACT,
WHICH IS GOING TO MAKE ILLINOIS
THE FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO
GO WITH NO BAIL.
SO PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD COMMITTED
CRIMES LIKE SECOND DEGREE
MURDER, ARSON, BURGLARY, THESE
FOLKS WON'T BE HELD.
YOU GOT OTHER POLICIES IN
CHICAGO LIKE THE NO CHASE POLICY
IMPLEMENTED BY MAYOR LORI
LIGHTFOOT AND IT'S ENDANGERED
THE LIVES OF SO MANY PEOPLE AND
WE SEE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DEMOCRATS HAVE USED CRIME AS
THEIR PLATFORM TO GET VOTES.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE RUNNING
FOR CRIMINALS OR WHAT THE DEAL
IS BUT IT'S REALLY IMPACTING ALL
OF US, AND WE SEE WE GOT SOMEONE
WHO'S RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR ON
THIS VERY ISSUE AND IS IMPACTED
IN HIS VERY OWN DOORSTEP WHILE
HIS TWIN DAUGHTERS ARE AT HOME.
THIS IS A HORRIFIC ISSUE AND I
HOPE PEOPLE ARE WAKING UP.
SEAN: JACKI, GIANNO MAKES A GOOD
MORNING.
SEE ZELDIN I SERVED WITH IN
CONGRESS AND I'M A FRIEND OF HIS
AND SAYING YOU NEED A GOVERNOR
OR POLITICIAN THAT WILL ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM ON OUR DOORSTEP,
HIS LITTLE DOORSTEP, AND I'M THE
GUY THAT WILL DO IT.
IT'S NOT JUST NEW YORK CITY.
WE'RE SEEING CRIME ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
I THINK SOMETIMES ON SHOWS LIKE
THIS, WE FOCUS A LOT ON NEW YORK
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIVE HERE, BUT
CRIME IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN
THE CAMPAIGN IN WISCONSIN THAT
RON JOHNSON IS RUNNING.
JACKIE: YEAH, IT'S NOT JUST NEW
YORK CITY BUT BIG CITIES 234 THE
COUNTRY AND SPREAD THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
NEW YORK STAYS IS HAVING A
PROBLEM AND IT'S BEEN A
CAMPAIGNING, FOR HIM AND ZELDIN
KNOWS HOW TO TACKLE IT AND YOU
HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT AND HE'S
DOING THAT.
SECOND OF ALL, REMOVE THE
LIBERAL DAS ALLOWING THESE
REPEAT OFFENDERS TO KEEP COMING
BACK ON THE STREETS AND KEEP
COMMITTING THE SAME KINDS OF
CRIMES, YOU KNOW, TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT WHY THE DEMOCRATS USE
THIS, THEY MAKE IT ABOUT
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
GIANNO: THIS IS NOT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
THIS IS JUSTICE FOR THE
CRIMINALS.
THAT'S WHAT WE SEE.
JACKIE: WITH RESPECT TO LEE
ZELDIN AND THIS HAPPENING IN HIS
BACKYARD, HE SAYS "THE TWO
INDIVIDUALS SHOT WERE LAYING
DOWN UNDER MY FRONT PORCH AND
THE BUSHES ON MY FRONT PORCH.
I UNDERSTAND THEY'VE BEGUN
TRANSPORTED TO AREA HOSPITALS
BUT I DON'T KNOW THEIR
IDENTITIES".
IT'S HAPPENING IN HIS BACKYARD
AND IT'S HAPPENING TO US AND
WE'VE HAD EXPERIENCE IN THIS
CITY AND OTHER CITIES WHERE WE
TURN AROUND AND SAY I'M SCARED
TO GO OUTSIDE SOMETIMES.
SEAN: JURY SCARED FOR YOUR KIDS.
AT HOME HEARING GUNSHOTS AND
THIS IS REAL FOR SO MANY PARENTS
BUT ROBERT CAHALEY, HE SAYS
CRIME IS GALVANIZING VOTERS AND
THEY'RE GOING TO THE POLLS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE SEE CRIME EMERGING AS A
VERY BIG ISSUE, AND I THINK
ANNOYS AT THE WAWA IN
PHILADELPHIA IS REALLY GOING TO
BE SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO JUST KIND OF
GALVANIZE VOTERS AND REALIZE HOW
OUR CONTROL THE CRIME SITUATION
IS IN PHILADELPHIA, IN
PENNSYLVANIA AS A WHOLE.
SEAN: WATCH THE FULL INTERVIEW
TONIGHT ON LIFE, LIBERTY AND
LAVIN BUT GALVANIZING VOTERS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ON CRIME?
LARA: IT IS A BIG ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY AND I THINK INFLATION
AND PROBABLY THE ECONOMY NUMBER
ONE BUT NOTHING REALLY MATTERS
IF YOU AREN'T SAFE, IF YOU DON'T
FEEL LIKE YOU CAN WALK DOWN THE
STREET OR RAISE YOUR KIDS IN A
SAFE WAY, THEN REALLY I MEAN
THAT'S A PRETTY BASIC NEED THAT
NEEDS TO BE MET.
THEY TALK ABOUT THAT WAWA
INCIDENT WAS INCREDIBLE.
IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THE VIDEO,
IT LOOKS LIKE JUST AN ARMY OF
PEOPLE COMING INTO THIS
CONVENIENT STORE AND, I MEAN,
IT'S A REALLY SCARY THING.
IT WAS SO -- LOOK AT THAT.
IT'S OVERWHELMING TO THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK THERE.
WHAT ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO DO?
THAT IS REALLY FRIGHTENING IF
THAT BECOMES COMMON PLACE IN
AMERICA.
WE SEE IT HAPPEN ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, AND I DO THINK, SEAN,
IT'S GOING TO BE A BIG ISSUE AND
A REASON THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE GO
OUT AND VOTE.
GIANNO: IT IS ALREADY COMMON
PLACE IN AMERICA.
SENATOR TUBERVILLE THAT I
INTERVIEWED ON CAPITOL HILL SAID
IT'S NOT JUST HAPPENING IN BIG
CITIES.
ONE OF HIS FRIENDS GOT MUGGED IN
A SUBURB SO IT'S NOT JUST
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS IN THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD.
IT'S NOT JUST IN BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS AND LATINO
NEIGHBORHOODS, EVERYONE IS AT
RISK AND THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE NEED
TO KNOW.
LARA: THAT SHOOTING WAS IN
SUFFICIENT FOLK COUNTY, NEW
YORK, FOR THAT DEMOCRAT.
SEAN: NOSE ISSUES MEAN NOTHING
IF YOU CAN'T PUT GAS IN YOUR
CARS AND REPUBLICANS ARE R